earlier you learned that every element
on the Wikipedia webpage seemed to be a
box even the completely not rectangular
images but wait how can everything be a
box I mean there are other shapes in the
world like circles right well that is
very true on a website something may
look like a circle or a triangle or
something a little more irregular but in
fact it's still just a box it just looks
like a circle don't believe it neither
did I the first time let's take a look
at this demo site on this site we have
three very nice circles and we've even
got a triangle I mean these can't just
be rectangles right or can they right
clicking on the first circle and
selecting inspect element brings up
Google developer tools in the exact
location where the circle is located in
the structure wait what my mind was just
blown so what exactly is going on here
in this Left panel we have the structure
that were already so familiar with and
this part seems to define our circle if
I highlight this line in developer tools
it highlights a rectangular shape on the
page but where does the visible round
shape come from I talked a little
something about style earlier so the
answer is probably in the style panel
here on the right what you see here are
the Styles used to display the element
selected in the left panel the very cool
thing is that you can change the style
and immediately see the results so for
example maybe I don't want an even
number of pixels for width and height
maybe I want to change this 200 to 100
what happens looks like we have more of
an oval than a circle and maybe I don't
like the color green but I don't know
what color I want my circle to be if I
click on this little color square it
brings
a selection tool where I can select any
color in the visible spectrum let's go
with blue now go ahead open this page
the link is provided to you in the
instructor notes section and play around
with the style of the circles on your
own particularly take a look at what
happens if you uncheck the border-radius
property and if at any time you decide
that your changes got a little too crazy
and you want to go back to normal
you can just refresh the page so what
did happen when you unchecked
border-radius did the circle disappear
did the circle turn into a square did
the circle become smaller or did nothing
happen